tonight Iran is bracing for what figures
to be a major blow to its already shaky
economy Monday the u.s. Rhian poses
tough sanctions that were eased during
the Iran nuclear deal State Department
correspondent Richardson tells us what's
in store for next week from the State
Department good evening rich I get
evening bread and Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo says the administration is
targeting the core of Iran's economy and
essentially exiting its participation in
the Iran nuclear deal on Monday the US
will restore sanctions against Iran's
oil banking and shipping sectors the
administration says these sanctions will
hit 700 individuals entities vessels and
aircraft it is aimed at the privately
the regime of the revenues that it uses
to spread death and destruction around
the world our ultimate aim is to compel
Iran to permanently abandon its well
documented outlaw activities and behave
as a normal country these sanctions will
penalize those importing Iran's oil
except eight as yet named countries
officials say they've given these
countries more time because they've
worked with the administration to reduce
their Iranian oil imports they're
expected to include India Japan South
Korea and possibly China though some
Republicans like Senator Marco Rubio
--tz-- say they are concerned quote
sanctions waivers being given to keep
purchasers of Iranian oil most
alarmingly China give Iran a financial
reprieve and should be eliminated as
soon as possible Rubio also says the
administration must do more to cut Iran
from the international finance system
and an entity called Swift which helps
enable international transactions
Treasury secretary Steve minuchin says
Swift will cut off all sanctioned backs
as soon as it's technically possible
Britain Germany and France and the
European Union they're still committed
to the Iran nuclear deal
they say the nuclear agreement quote
provides for the lifting of
international sanctions in order to have
a positive impact on trade and economic
relations with Iran but most importantly
on the lives of the Iranian people they
say they are committed to help conduct
business with Iran has allowed under the
nuclear agreement and despite US
sanctions Brett Richardson live the
State Department rich thank you